[Musique]
après six années de consultations et de
débats le quai saint-esprit retrouve le
cours de l'histoire
l'architecte michel en point de boyer
propose une restauration fidèle à
l'esprit du quai l'escalier d'autrefois
était de l'autre côté du mur du côté de
la saône
il occupait la plateforme où l'on voit
en bas l'avoir mis en retraite un gros
avantage
ça libère la plateforme qui va nous
permettre de lancer des aménagements sur
l'eau et à en même temps on était en
retrait on ne se pose plus aux flots
d'inondations il ya une évolution de la
construction mais dans le fil de
l'histoire l'histoire degrés est
indissociable de la somme la rivière
relie le rhône en amont et le nord de
l'europe en aval dès le xiiie siècle on
embarque des barils de farine de
l'avoine et du vin apparaissent alors
les premiers moulins ainsi que le
déversoir caractéristiques avec sa forme
en veille à l'origine il n'y avait que
les moulins il était un peu en amont et
le déversoir
il était d'une ligne tirait tout droit
depuis l'arrêt droite jusqu'à la rive
gauche pour amener l'eau sur les moulins
mais ensuite se construisent
lécluse le barrage vannes et ont rétréci
et petit à petit le barrage change de
forme et prend cette forme en v 150000
bateau remonte la saône à la fin du
xviie siècle
le trafic ne cessera d'augmenter
jusqu'au début du 19ème le port alors
situé sur la rive droite nécessite des
aménagements en 18h22 et crée le quai
avec talia gradins c'est la première
forme en dur de porc et le modèle est
repris de ce côté-ci en 1840 pour
refaire un second quai avec telle vague
rada les archives attestent de
l'existence donc on ne voit reliant les
deux rives des presses 158 emporté par
les eaux les glaces il est reconstruit
plusieurs fois pendant près de trois
cents ans jusqu'à la construction d'un
pont de pierre saez 103 sa forme
actuelle est le résultat de
transformations successives en 1881
cette fois ci on élargit le pont
lui-même vers l'amont d'un tiers de
largeur pour ce faire on démonte les
façades existantes ont construit le
corps du pont et on remet haute
l'ancienne façade que l'on connaît
aujourd'hui
la fin du 19ème avec la création du
canal de l'est et l'ouverture du chemin
de fer marque la fin de la navigation
marchande sur la zone laissant place
aujourd'hui à la navigation de plaisance
[Musique]